teachers in England Wells are going to
go on strike wave of winter strike
action Julian Keegan is the education
secretary with me this morning good
morning and good morning kids on the
program
um how could you avoid these strikes
well we've been doing what we can when I
very first started the job on the 25th
of October I had um you know the first
day I had a letter from all four unions
and it basically said we need an extra
two billion pounds next year and the
year after to pay for these uh increases
in pay and also the cost of living to
help schools with the cost of living so
that was the first challenge I was given
and we did secure that in the Autumn
statement so it's deeply disappointing
actually that one of the unions is only
one has um you know just scraped over
the line to get
um you know I think under half the
teachers voted for it but about 50 cents
53 turnout 90 percent voted for it so I
think it's just under half that actually
voted to strike in one Union in one
Union Yes and it will impact on many of
our children did pay come up in your
last meeting when you met with the Neu
because yeah I had the leader the
general secretary and she said that
you'd never even talked about pair when
she came in to see you we talked about
pay we talked about mostly in relation
to the pay review body of next year so
what is happening at the moment is the
submissions that we all put in and
everyone puts a submission into unions
the employers the government they take
lots of other inputs so in terms of
recruitment retention what's happening
in other sectors Etc and then they look
at all of that we've got to have that in
by the 27th of January so that's what
we're all working on to make sure that
we can see if we can try and come closer
together when we look at pay for the
next pay review body but Mary barstad
said and this is what she said we talked
about that education was very important
that teachers are very important and we
talked a bit about inflation and we
counted that wage Rises are causing
inflation but no we didn't talk about
money and we didn't talk about money
either for this year or next year well
what happened is we had a sort of wider
discussion and then the officials who
were going to go through all the line by
line submissions for the 27th followed
up with a meeting on the Friday then
we've got another meeting this week on
Wednesday and there's another meeting
with officials all day did you talk
about money with it we talked about it
in general but we didn't talk we didn't
go through line by line of the
submission because they were doing they
were starting to do that with the
officials but we talked about you know
the the principles of what the do you
know I think it would have been
important to talk about money and
potentially you could have fended off
this strike well you know what we've
done in terms of money is get the budget
to pay for the independent pay review
bodies and one thing that's important
when you look at because there's a lot
of information on pay so there's a five
percent rise for experienced teachers
and 8.9 rise for new teachers that's on
the bands the way a lot of public sector
pay works is you then get progression
within the bands so if you actually look
at almost every newly qualified teacher
and about 40 of experienced teachers
will actually be getting up to 15.9
because it will also include the
progression award as well they get
either for promotion or for progression
over time and then of course you've got
other benefits as well so it is
um you know an offer that the
independent pay-per-view body has put
together it's a lot higher than we put
in it's a lot higher than schools
budgeted but you're an education
secretary the unions come in to see you
why don't you talk about money well we
didn't talk about money but they're
saying that you didn't
well they also said I only met with them
for 45 minutes I was with them an hour
and 10 minutes um but but we did talk
about money but we did it wrong to say
that we didn't negotiate the pay that's
not what we're there to do we didn't
negotiate pay but what we did do was
talk about some of the challenges uh
workload challenges as well we talked
about and we we've gone through for next
year and we will by now they will have
gone through
um but there's a I think it's a six hour
meeting that's scheduled on Friday to go
through line by line so she's being
disingenuous to say that she came out
and you wouldn't talk about money
um I mean you know we talked about money
we talked about workload actually the
number one reason teachers leave
um and the retention rates are actually
the second lowest actually the numbers
for last year since 2010 at the rate
level but the the you know the number
one reason teachers leave is workload
and flexibility they want more
flexibility job shares being able to do
part-time that kind of thing so so
they're the things that we really need
to focus on teachers are doing a
brilliant job they're helping our kids
catch up from the pandemic obviously
they've done delivered now about three
million catch-up lessons and tutoring
and they're doing the most amazing job
but we need children in school now
luckily obviously the head teachers
unions
um one of the teachers unions and the
teaching assistant unions have not voted
for strike action so it's only one of
the teachers unions that has and we
issue guidance last night to head
teachers to try and uh well hopefully we
can keep as many schools open as
possible
I mean almost what's the message to a
mom on a zero hours contract who has to
take time off work because she can't
send her child to school because it's
shot it's deeply disappointing I am very
disappointed it's you know I'm
disappointed in the one Union that has
decided to go on strike our children
don't deserve it to be honest we do need
to keep teachers and children in school
and I will work with you know you don't
need to strike to get my attention I
will meet with people I'll be as
constructive as possible but we do need
to be fair and and the the number one
thing we need to do is tattle inflation
I've said that to you before there's no
point what we need to do is halve
inflation that's obviously what what uh
we've said we'll do
um and go be further Beyond but you know
more than that okay talk to me about the
gender reform uh Bill Nicholas sturgeon
said the decision by Richardson actor
blocked Scotland's gender Reform Bill is
a full frontal attack on our
democratically elected Scottish
Parliament and its ability to make its
own decisions on devolved matters what
do you think
um well I wouldn't agree with that I
mean the Scotland act deliberately was
set up with this power in it and I think
it was set up about 25 years ago
anticipating that there could be times
when legislation uh when it looked a bit
messy or there was legislation that
could potentially be competing and it
was set up I mean it was legislation
written by a labor government voted for
by the SMP so everybody agreed on the
the Scotland Act and the structure of it
and the fact that there would be this
power and when it was to be used and
obviously what we can't have is um you
know a lack of clarity in law in terms
of you know gender gender recognition
having two sort of schemes in place
across Great Britain so that's but I
don't understand those comments because
it was something they voted for it was
deliberately designed in the Scotland
act to help us navigate whether where
any of these sort of difficulties or
things that were less clear would you be
content for children in your schools at
16 to be able to say that they wanted to
change their gender and be able to do
that we have to be very sensitive to
Children you know it's not it's not we
are actually going to publish some
guidance and consult because it is a
very tricky area to get right to get it
has to be age-appropriate and but
children have to be supported as well so
I think what would you think 16 is too
young
um well I mean the the key thing will be
to have that discussion through the
consultation but what do you think
um no I don't actually I think 16 you
know I was working at 16. I was paying
tax at 16. I was could make decisions
for myself at 16.
um but you know it's not really about
what I think it's how we make sure we
get that right balance of supporting
children but also making sure that what
they're getting taught in schools is age
appropriate
um I'm sure you've got a view on this
how can we have faith in our police
force when one of them has just admitted
to 49 charges including 24 rapes it's
unbelievable it's really shocking and
appalling case and and obviously the
first thoughts are to the victims many
victims and their families
um and yeah it's really deeply shocking
actually what should they might be doing
about it well I think they are they I
mean obviously the matters come out and
they've apologized they've said they've
done a lot in terms of their vetting
procedures there's more they're doing I
think they've referred themselves to
this case to the independent police
organization as well but clearly they
they've got some work to do they do it's
really really important that we have
that trust in our police and of course
you know High sort of profile cases like
this or Wayne cousins does damage that
and so I think the the police have more
to do and the Met police have said that
they're going to be doing that okay um
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much today for taking the time thank you
good morning thank you